yeah
president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Putin
hello
um
hello colleagues
before we begin the discussion I would
like to show you Mr Putin and you
colleagues and our participants in our
discussion today we have Alex a
furtherov next to us who is the head of
the Russian Quantum Center and the
youngest professor
and the head of rosatum is here
built the computer that you Mr Putin saw
today
Ilya heads the subgroup
and at The Institute of physics and we
have also nadesh dabarshevska who works
at the quantum Technology Center at the
Moscow State University
Oleg Feliz zorov head of Russian
Railways and Vladimir igorov who is the
Deputy head of the Quantum Internet
Center
Mr Putin wave just had a chat with the
scientists and you said that happiness
is in creativity
and we've been discussing the same
same idea that we are living at a time
we as the science community at a time
that's a very happy time for us because
so much is happening
that our creative paths
can be compared
we've covered so much in 10 days that
sometimes takes a lifetime for others
my colleague here I remember when we
were students and we were talking about
what quantum computer is and people were
telling us that sci-fi
and now they are asking
when are you going to complete
everything
in the Russian nuclear industry
we have come a long way
and today we're talking about technology
but also about people how they lived all
this time and how we have approached
this event this forum that we could not
have imagined 10 day 10 years ago
could not have imagined that the state
would pay so much attention to Quantum
technology but before we begin the
discussion I would like to ask you Mr
Putin to address us
thank you very much I don't think this
will be a fundamental speech
because
the subjects you are discussing are very
specific
but I am glad to Welcome All Russian and
foreign scientists engineers business
representatives and all those taking
part in the future technology forum
the moderator said it was difficult to
imagine 10 years ago that this forum
would take place why why couldn't you we
always wanted forums like this and we've
always
strived
to have research to have young
scientists involved in research and to
reach the parameters and the results
and what we are trying to achieve that's
very important we are setting achievable
goals that our country needs we are
confidently on our way to achieving the
results
so I expect that today's meeting will
become a tradition
discussing promising areas
that are already on the horizon in this
decade and at the beginning of the next
decade will gain more and more momentum
and much of this will start looking like
we will start to define the map of the
world as well as the national economies
I'm not going to talk about purely
scientific things today because that's
for those sitting here next to me or at
least some of them
and
nobody knows this better than you
Specialists but I thought it would be
important to tell you how we are
constructing our work at the state level
how we are constructing International
and international technological
cooperation in the conditions of a
blockade that the ruling Elites of some
countries more than anyone have
organized we are seeing access
as prevented from accessing
International technology
we have to achieve sovereignty we have
to achieve our own historical path our
opponents want us to give up
but that will not happen as we often say
Russia will only go forward
following its own path without isolating
itself from anyone else
we respond to external challenges only
with quality work and spreading freedom
and this is what happened in 2014 I have
already spoken about this when the first
wave of external sanctions gave a boost
to
super fast development in many areas
including agriculture today similar
processes are taking place in industry
and in technology we understand that in
these conditions
the most important thing for development
is to focus our efforts on priority
tasks
those areas where we already have
technology and at the global level such
as nuclear industry out artificial
intelligence and other areas
and secondly on those areas that are
critical for the country's development
and where we must absolutely
have our own competency
and these should not be just scientific
or basic Solutions but the entire
technological and production chain our
own equipment software
and hardware and of course people human
resources
while solving the tasks of a
technological sovereignty we are not
going to isolate ourselves on the
contrary we plan to create and extend
equal mutually beneficial alliances with
other countries
I will say that as part of Russian
chairmanship of brics we will discuss
specific projects with our partners in a
number of significant areas first of all
these are state-of-the-art Computing
data transmission and Storage
I will dwell on that topic in detail if
you if I may
especially as this issue is in the
center of attention for this forum this
year
our fundamental task is to transfer our
whole economy and social sphere
government and its work
to a qualitative new principle of
working on the basis of Big Data the
effect will as we expect be full
comprehensive and multiplying this will
be a qualitatively new level of Labor
Management new competencies and high
salaries
accessible service and new opportunities
for our people
digital platforms will create and
develop smart cities and unmanned
systems
processes of production accurate
Precision
Agriculture and a new level of logistics
and engine power engineering
telemedicine and online education
State services
and financial settlements on the whole
platform Solutions will open up the path
of fully automating not only the
technological process but also the
interrelations between markets
participants
for these changes everything that's to
do with big data is critically important
we are talking about a system forming
infrastructure for our future
development for the future of the
economy as a whole
and it is obvious that dependence in
this area poses a serious risk to
National Security the weakening or even
loss of the country's sovereignty we
must absolutely think about it as we
look to the Future let us be Frank this
is what some countries
we're trying to achieve when they tried
by a fair means of foul to get us
dependent on foreign standards and
platforms and it wasn't without success
clearly dependence is inevitable and is
an objective phenomenon
but
between General words about openness
and our own shirt that is closer to the
body there is a difference between those
Notions and I have seen it in practice
we bought technology in someone else's
shop a sort of Supermarket of ready
off-the-shelf Solutions and it's one
point the door was shut to us with the
label closed
we drew lessons and conclusions
the government and the private business
have done a lot to change the situation
but undoubtedly we must go forward we
must solve more complex systemic tasks
and to plan this work for the long term
I proposed within this within a year to
prepare a new National project until
a national project to form the economy
of data
this isn't only about consolidating
existing existing tools of supporting
digital economy artificial intelligence
and high technology projects including
road maps on the development of quantum
technology that you mentioned
and which today companies some with the
state share are trying to implement
we must build a whole mechanism of
comprehensive implementation of
state-of-the-art design
and This concerns all areas of life and
Technology we talk a lot about it we are
moving gradually towards this and
solving these issues but we must boost
this work including in the area of the
economy of data
everything is significant here research
training at every level of Education
creating conditions for the output and
trialing new specimens
uh creating demand for Russian service
and data processing and computation and
support for production it is
fundamentally important to take a
systemic view of the next technological
system create markets for the future
this is the logic driving the national
project for unmanned aerial systems as
we agreed
with the colleagues so let us approve it
by the 1st of September 2023 and also
consider this priority area When
developing the budget for 2024 and for
the planned period until 2026. dear
colleagues
the new national projects to form the
economy of data must cover all the
stages and levels of work firstly this
is data collection I mean also sensitive
sensors including Quantum sensors which
radically improve the accuracy of
positioning discover disease at an early
stage and are used in other
areas such as satellite systems
a second data transmission in
communication system not only in this
generation of this generation and all of
next Generations that can transmit data
in real time which is critically
important to develop unmanned Transport
Systems and to automate
the city infrastructure third is this
modern system for computing
and data storage I mean Cloud
Technologies and data processing systems
that can effectively support the work of
the state authorities
companies
Communications companies and our own
production
I mean on new based on new principles I
mean computers using Quantum and photon
technology that we have talked about
fourth data security
of course we must consider this aspect
fully I mean I think it is important and
is necessary to continue the work on the
technology of quantum Communications and
Quantum did and quantums coding
and this will make systems resilient to
cyber attacks using
um quantum computers and will create
systems that will be impenetrable
and also will protect existing Quantum
Communications Russia is one of the
leaders in this area and of course we
are only making the first steps as the
colleagues are saying but it is a
tangible result number five these are
sovereign national standards and
protocols for data work these are
required for safe storage and processing
including personal information
to use quantum technology and
cryptography and cyber security to
protect from attacks
number six algorithm data processing
including to extend the use of
artificial intelligence and software
these National instruments will
guarantee data sovereignty and
considerably reduce dependence on
foreign suppliers and improve control
over critical infrastructure of course
we must also have code storage platforms
and services the Russian platforms and
services that are needed to support
programmers not only in Russia but also
in other countries
on in all these areas work must focus on
systemic change in all the areas of the
economy the social sector
uh
public governance and the quality of
life of across our country dear
colleagues now I would like to address
Quantum Technologies which are the main
subject of today's discussion I have
been to the exhibition and chatting I've
been chatting to scientists I was
instructed or they tried to instruct me
in in this area in more detail
we need not only to solve ongoing tasks
but also we must look to the Future
Beyond the Horizon we must expand the
potential of the human being
make the most complex physical processes
serve the human being the quantum world
isn't ready to open all its Secrets but
Russian scientists are ready to solve
the most complex tasks and to open up
the path to Advanced Solutions and I
will repeat
we will support this
I would like the national project on the
data economy to Define measures of
supporting fundamental research and
increase its funding I mean first of all
research across the whole spectrum of
computing technology
much of which is based on quantum
physics and mechanics
and this is um
also concerning the first and the second
ongoing Quantum Revolution that our
moderator was talking about at the
exhibition the second revolution which
became a boost for Quantum Computing and
quantum computers
and every every forecast sees these
Computing systems as hybrid Solutions
which contain the quantum core and the
classic microelectronics technology I
will say that every 10 years computer
productivity gets a thousand times
greater
the systems contain tens of billions of
transistors this race is super fast
the latest computer are produced by
spare can take care of 13 trillion
transactions per second
and children's computer are almost twice
as powerful now these are not number one
positions in the world but they are
significant
notable and we can respect them there is
a prospect for the for their development
and the demand for resources is only
going great getting greater and so which
is critically important for the
development of
artificial intelligence and World
Network models that's why it is very
important for us to
um to develop a Russian microelectronic
outputs we are working on serial
production of pure materials many know
that in Zelena grad we are creating a
new Research Center implementing
projects on technology equipment and
with together with Partners from Belarus
I will remind you that this high level
of cooperation in the Soviet Union
provides it the environment for engine
engineer training
for the development of unique technology
and unique
schools including in photonics
thanks to that investment today's
integral systems is fully operational
Moscow has an integrated cluster of
photonics
which encompasses startups businesses
universities working together on New
Solutions and their implementation
also based on the platform experimenting
with future Technologies their testing
and practical implementation these
platforms must be
created for other areas I know the
government of Moscow and the mayor is
here today we have spoken to him about
this the Moscow government has begun
work on the Moscow Quantum cluster and I
would like to ask you Sergey
to to
tell us about it in detail or at least
in general about that
dear colleagues I have met Russian
scientists and our competitors in
foreign working in foreign universities
and research centers just recently again
many of them want to work in Russia and
be part of interesting significant
projects
they also ask about resuming the work of
our Mega grant program which collect
bring together research teams working on
interesting research tasks I support
fully this proposal and would like the
government and the Duma to provides in
the federal budget until 2026
to provide for the necessary funding of
Mega grants and to change the parameters
of the program so that its terms are
even more attractive to scientists
I would like to increase the maximum
ceiling for Mega grants and it is
important as colleagues told me recently
prolong the implementation the life of
the project
some say even to 10 years but I'll say
to five extendable by another three so
that's almost 10.
first of all we must support large
scientific projects by the leading
foreign researchers and our compatriots
those who already were part of creating
of the teams creating world-class
Laboratories in Russia
within five years scientists must the
scientist must receive a half a billion
rubles per project provided they're
ready to work permanently in Russia
a quarter of a billion rubles over five
years will be provided to foreign
leading Sciences who are ready to come
to Russia create departments in our
universities teach work with students
and postgraduate students
this is not that different from the
previous terms but we will confirm and
extend them as a result
such colleagues will form scientific
schools in key the key areas of Science
and Technology and another fundamentally
new area as part of the updated Mega
grant program we will provide support to
promising new scientists including our
compatriots who want to return to Russia
and contribute significantly to
Scientific and technological solutions
there are many of them
I will stress the updated Mega ground
Pro program must be launched as soon as
possible we will be glad to welcome
scientists to our country who share the
principle of the openness of Science and
who devote their life to scientific
research who are focusing on projects of
the future and we for our part will do
everything we can to make sure that
tomorrow's Pro
projects will be competitive on the
global stage and I would like to thank
everybody who is taking part in this
great joint effort Ross Congress in
particular that's organizing our Forum
the Russian Quantum Center the state
company Ross atom the Russian Railways
whose leaders are here today Innovative
companies the leading research
institutes and universities for their
technological breakthroughs and for
their constant desire to go forward
separate thanks are due to the Russian
Academy of Sciences for their in-depth
assessment of technological research
projects
dear colleagues I would like you to
expand not only your experts but also
methodological support for the national
development programs
I will add that this year the Russian
Academy of Sciences will be 300 years
old
and at this stage of its development the
Russian Academy of Sciences brings
together
scientists
and business solving the tasks of our
country's technological and scientific
sovereignty in this close cooperation
they will be preparing for the next
forum which will next year be developed
devoted to neurocognitive and biomedical
technology
thank you for your attention
thank you Mr Putin that was a
fundamental speech we will work on that
we could draw some parallels while
listening to you to your speech about
people the closed sign we did really
feel that when the door was shut to us
many doors were shut to us but that is a
challenge we are working we showed you
what we were trying to do our Spirits
are high
but when we discuss these things we
often raise the question but who are we
what are we and what are the symbols of
New Times
in
1937 the sculptor mukhina created the
skull the sculpture of the worker and
the farmer the woman I'm glad you
remembered that
and not something else in 1937.
well we are positive this is a positive
forum
but in the 60s when scientists managed
to conquer the atom
there was an expression
physicists versus lyricists and the role
of the physicist was powerful physicists
often saved others at that time
and then in the 90s that was difficult
for science in the last 20 years we see
great changes so we are asking ourselves
now as we discuss these challenges
are we not Heroes of the new time
of course we are not trying to take up
the pedestal we respect other
professions but what do you think about
the role of the scientists
is it worthy of that
of as a hero well the scientist is
always is a Pioneer it's always first
he is the
fanatic and only Fanatics achieve
success
number two
every time needs its own Heroes
in the 60s or even before
if you recall 1937
that was started with barrier who led
the nuclear project and dealt with the
missile project that started and back
then the time demanded results in that
area and the people who worked in that
area Were Heroes in the public
conscience
times are different now
the priorities are different
and it is not difficult
to test them
the latest public opinion survey by
futsium the state public opinion
Research Center said it was the most
popular job among young people 30
percent
the doctor was second 30 percent wanted
to be doctors number three the defender
of the father learned a serviceman of
the army
and so on
but the number the interest
among young people for engineering
professions multiplied it was almost
five-fold
and all this proves that
despite the fact that some things
are within the focus
of people and I'm not going to describe
each of these areas but the fact that
the interests for engineering
professions is multiplying that is a
sign of our times
and as for scientists they are pioneers
they are at the Forefront
they are well as you know you know
better than me
many in the Bell Prize winners receive
these prizes decades after the
discoveries they made
but when they were making those
discoveries they were not thinking of
those Awards
they just went forth and we always must
bow our heads as a sign of respect
to those people to that kind of
character
thank you I wanted to talk about
fanatics
among our community of scientists
is a fanatic and which is scary but it
is also quite fun please Ilya tell us
about it
yes I am a fanatic
foreign
started not yesterday and not before
it started in 2015 when I understood
that I didn't want to be an
astrophysicist but I wanted to be in
Quantum Optics and I came to the
laboratory of theoretical astrophysics
and I asked
could I join and I'm thankful
that even though I couldn't really do
anything yet he said I could
and two other people joined
they were students back then
and we started working it turns out we
were very different
and almost every solution took hours we
were shouting at one another
until we lost our voices
but despite these differences
every time we remember that
our soul goal
is to build a quantum computer before
that we had other tasks
so this diversity and respect for each
other
I would say even love
allows us to look at each problem from
different sides and find
Solutions
so we began to work together
and it was important for us because to
learn something is only possible when
you are actually doing real work yes we
were students but in order to do
something real you need to do it
and we did that between 15 2015 and
2017.
then we began to apply it
thank you
um
the main thing is for you not to retire
thank you
foreign
you know I can only Envy you I can
sympathize with those who are thinking
about going to work tomorrow sadly but
for you going to work is joy that is
happiness when someone
is living for their life's work
I will share something with you
I am far from that sort of state of mind
but I when I'm asked how did you come to
this idea my answer is always simple
because I think about it day and night I
go to bed and think about it I wake up
and think about it and the solution
comes very suddenly so I think that's
the Paradigm your own
thank you
don't forget your wife that'll cost you
dearly
yes our wives are heroes
thank you
yes the road map and the first results
are important maybe rosatom can comment
s
okay
sure
information
thank you
foreign
everything
again
thank you
foreign
information
eleven
years
thank you
what can I say I can only agree
with that's what we'll do I can agree
that we need to support young scientists
we have more and more of them and that
is good you mentioned Laboratories
that we acquired as a result of Mega
grants we have many
uh
346 if I'm correct not only at leading
research centers but in at least another
10 centers cities that
uh have uh never had good scientific
schools but as part of this work and as
proposed by the scientists themselves
who were conducting This research
in the Innovative Laboratories they
proposed
creating an environment for young
scientists and that's what we did and
today these Laboratories
uh in 50 of their staff are young
scientists and
postgraduate students and lots is yet to
be done and we need to help them with
their everyday life and create
the physical environment
um
tools and we will do all that
thank you Mr Putin the discussion is
very interesting and as always we are
short of time so I would like everybody
to have shorter speeches
so we can cover everyone
thank you
business
ES
image
foreign
thank you
very much
um
thank you
Railway transports in Russia has a
special significance it is
a fundamental
industry like Power Engineering it
underpins the entire economy
security speeds
safety are among many important factors
here and the fact that the industry
doesn't stand still and is developing
based on state-of-the-art technology
that is extremely important that can
only be welcome
to be frank
um Olex just said that you you supported
this and you supported that I am proud
that I did nothing I did not stand in
the way and they managed everything
I want to thank them for that
thank you
well I can only wish you success
you have shown me a quantum computer
so it's like somebody says can you know
something when you approach it for the
first time it is impressive
Computing based on super computers
could take
hundreds of years when quantum computers
achieved the result in hours
and that is impressive
and you begin to understand
how important these technology this
technology of the future is to any
economy and to all areas of life I can
only wish you success and we will give
you all the support you need
thank you Mr Putin you mentioned Sergey
sabanyan the mayor of Moscow who is
creating the Moscow Quantum cluster I
would like to give him the microphone to
comment
Mr Putin and colleagues you asked me to
be more active in supporting Photon
technology and Quantum technology in
Moscow it is logical because we have
many
Enterprises that are world class in this
area as for futon technology we created
Photon clusters
and microelectronics and photonics
cluster
and we
determined that the central project in
this cluster which brings together 50
companies in Moscow is the creation of
photonic integral schemes
this is technology that allows to speed
up data transmission 100 times and this
is the technology that
isn't some kind of sci-fi it is
something that is used in many countries
and if we fall behind with this
technology
we will have to get off the shelf
products and queue up for this
technology
we began to build a laboratory
industrial center in Zelena grad it will
be completed next year and we hope that
in 2025 we will receive the first output
that will that should
provide consumers in our country and
these are mobile phone operators data
processing centers
and so on
will be able to reduce their energy
consumption speed up data transmission
and the economy will change
as for Quantum technology we work in two
areas
together with the colleagues present
here
we signed an agreement
to create
Communications a Quantum communications
center based on the luminosov center
that you and I opened recently
this will be one of the focus projects
of this cluster we also signed with Ross
atom and the Space Center
an agreement to build
and laboratory and Industrial Center in
school cover
that must be completed by next before
next year
to create new startups new technology
new prototypes
we do not do science
our task is to help create the
infrastructure and to help different
companies come together on these
platforms and also to find buyers for
their products
including industrial companies in Moscow
and
city services
as Alexa said
Health transport Urban Development and
so on
this technology must be implemented
today there should be Solutions
for those
working on Industrial technology to uh
to help them understand where their
consumers are
is it working
communication
foreign
according to many independent competent
experts Moscow is one of the best mega
policies in the world on many parameters
and it's enough just to look at it look
at the transport infrastructure you will
recall just 10 years ago it was
considered
that moscow's transport problems could
be
could not be solved
but they are being solved I can't say
all of them are solved but they are
being solved effectively including with
the help of state-of-the-art technology
in transport in road construction of
course there's always room for criticism
towards the current government including
at the regional level because
this is too big an economy there will
always be drawbacks but on the whole
Moscow
is moving towards achieving maximum
results for Moscow residents for those
who come to work here and for visitors
to our capital and that is obvious and
that is also achieved
using modern technology we can all only
be glad and wish Moscow to continue
developing on the same course led by the
Moscow mayor and his team
thank you
we can think about that we'll talk about
that of course
but on the whole what do you think
about the standards
of Russian
Russian space science compared to
competitors
we are at the world standards in quantum
and quite behind in space science about
10 years behind behind China and other
countries
what are the prospects what do you think
we should do
in order to move forward
our Quantum Space Project is already on
the roadmap and it is about to start so
in three years time we plan to launch
the first satellite to test out
technology so there are specific steps
planned you mentioned your industrial
partner who is that that's the text
and how does it help you what tasks do
you solve for them this is a company
that brings our
designs into serial production but what
are you doing for them what do you do
for them
we
make we're just making the first steps
we think of what technology
uh
should be there for Quantum key
distribution
we do design
so already something being implemented
that's great well we'll talk about
student grants yeah
and scholarships thank you
we need it
the flip side of being a scientist is
that people are worried that you would
cancel science at this in these
difficult times so it's really good that
you came here and showed your support
and the fact that you're here standing
on the stage with our guys that is a
strong signal of support for us and
thank you for being here
foreign
government of the Russian Federation
cannot cancel science it is absolutely
out of the question
and there is no need to think that way
the Deputy Prime Minister is here
children schenko maybe you could say
anything could you say anything about
the government's intentions
and do you have to do you plan to cancel
science be honest
Mr Putin of course not we are fulfilling
your instruction
and we are in the latest program we
spend 2.9
000 billion rubles on science so science
is safe
so the deputy PM says that he is working
on my instructions and the government of
the Russian Federation is achieving
tangible results especially at this
difficult time today but as for Mega
grants
this
is the Minister of higher education they
need to look at the instructions they
should before and the government on the
whole I would like you to focus on that
because resources for 2025 have not been
planned yet that is true only for 2024
to
billion that is something you asked for
in 2010 and do you remember how many
Laboratories were created 246.
now 346 that is true
he spends no money for 2025 and he
doesn't remember the number of
Laboratories
well with your help the Ministry of
Finance will work on that
thank you it looks like we're
yes just a little bit more I will
correct to yes Mr Putin your speech
today is a huge inspiration
and a kind of medal
but every medal has a flip side
so I want to
talk to my colleagues in the quantum
Workshop that is a huge advance and the
next conference we must present a
qualitatively new level we will report
back yes next year I've already
announced the subject of the next forum
it is extremely interesting I just spoke
to colleagues about it one of the
fundamental areas of development
biotechnology and everything to do with
it
very interesting I'm certain that it
will be held at the similarly high level
like now and I want to I want to thank
the organizers for all the work they've
done to prepare and organize this forum
thank you very much thank you
Mr Putin we will look forward to seeing
you next year
all the best
foreign